Willkommen an der Militärakademie
in Wiener Neustadt.
Mein Name ist Oberst Markus Reisner.
Ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs und
Entwicklungsabteilung.
Und heute wollen wir uns in einem neuen
Video mit dem Einsatz von Drohnen
im Ukrainekonflikt befassen.
Tatsächlich, im Rahmen des Konflikt
Verlaufes sind unsere Betrachtungen sehr
zum Teil auf den Einsatz der
Landstreitkräfte konzentriert, also
Panzer, aber auch ballistische Raketen.
Interessant ist aber, dass gerade Drohnen
im Konflikt eine sehr große Rolle spielen
und das wollen wir uns
heute im Detail ansehen.
Zuerst wollen wir uns ansehen, wie
man diese Drohnen einteilen kann.
Es gibt drei Klassen von Drohnen.
Es gibt kleinere Drohnen wie diese
handelsüblichen chinesischen DJI Drohnen
bis zu großen militärischen Drohnen, die
die Größe eines Verkehrsflugzeug haben.
Drohnen kann man einteilen nach Gewicht,
nach Leistungsfähigkeit, auch in
der Distanz, auch nach Größe bzw.
Auch ob es ein
Flächenmodell ist oder zum Beispiel wie dieser
Helikopter mit Rotoren ausgestattet ist.
Hier habe ich das noch einmal im Detail
dargestellt, also Klasse
eins unter 150 Kilogramm.
Das kann man noch mal unterteilen in
Mikro, Mini oder Small oder auch taktische
Drohnen der Klasse 250 Kilogramm aufwärts
mit entsprechender Reichweite
von bis zu 200 Kilometern.
Darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich die
Klasse drei, also Drohnen über 600
Kilogramm, wie zum Beispiel
das System Mail Medium.
Vergleichbar mit dem bekannten Predator
oder Repertoire der
amerikanischen Streitkräfte.
Oder auch hier ist Beispiel diese Global
Hawk Drohne, die quasi die Größe eines
Verkehrsflugzeug hat und von
USA und NATO eingesetzt werden.
Gerade diese Drohne hat eine hohe
Bedeutung, denn wenn wir uns ansehen, dass
es so laufen Aufklärungsflüge stattfinden
von bemannten und unbenannten Luftfahrzeugen
entlang der Grenzen der Ukraine.
So sehen wir zum Beispiel hier den Einsatz
von RQ4 Drohnen im Schwarzen Meer zur
Aufklärung der russischen
Streitkräfte im Süden der Ukraine.
Was auch noch bedeutungsvoll ist, ist der
Zusammenhang zwischen der Größe der
Drohne und der Leistungsfähigkeit.
Je kleiner die Drohne, desto billiger und
desto geringer der technische Aufwand.
Und je größer die Drohne, desto größer
der Aufwand und auch die Möglichkeiten.
Hier ist auch der Unterschied von der
reinen Aufklärungsdrohne zu einer
bewaffneten Drohne zu sehen.
Hier im Bereich der kleineren Drohnen.
Das kann also auch nicht nur ein
handelsübliches Modell sein, sondern das
kann zum Beispiel auch über Crowdfunding
für die Streitkräfte zur
Verfügung gestellt werden.
So wie wir es sehen in der Ukraine, wo zum
Teil den Streitkräften
durch Sammeln von Geld Drohnen beschafft
werden, die dann quasi von
ihnen eingesetzt werden.
Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich
militärische Drohnen von einer
entsprechenden Größe, die dann auch
bewaffnet werden kann, die aber natürlich
dann von staatlichen Akteuren, zum
Beispiel im Rahmen von zusätzlichen
Lieferungen in das Land kommen.
Sehen wir uns zuerst die russischen
Modelle an Die russische Seite hat eine
ganze Reihe von Drohnen von der Klasse
eins und Klasse zwei kleinere Drohnen, die
sie einsetzt, aber auch taktische Drohnen,
wie zum Beispiel das Modell FORPOST oder
ORLAN10 sehen, das wir hier sehen können.
Zusätzlich setzen sie auch größere Drohnen
vom Typ Klasse drei, vergleichbar
der amerikanischen Predator.
Das ist das russische Modell ORION.
Es zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass es
nicht nur aufklären kann, sondern es kann
auch eine entsprechende Bewaffnung
mitnehmen und die dann zielgerichtet
zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Zusätzlich gibt es auch sogenannte Loitering
Munition, also quasi Kamikaze Drohnen, die
von russischer Seite eingesetzt werden,
wie zum Beispiel dieses Modell KUB-BLA,
wo wir wissen, dass es zum Beispiel
in Kiew schon eingesetzt worden ist.
Die russische Seite hat beim Einsatz von
Drohnen in den letzten Jahren viel
Erfahrung gesammelt, nicht nur in Syrien,
sondern vor allem auch in der Ukraine.
Hervorzuheben ist das Jahr 2014,
wo es dazu gekommen ist, dass russische
Drohnen zum Beispiel von dem FORPOST die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte aufgeklärt haben
in Grenznähe und dann gezielt durch den
Einsatz von Artillerie und mehrfach
Raketenwerfern zum Beispiel vom
Typ BM-30 bekämpft haben.
Interessant war auch der Einsatz von der
ORLAN 10 als Teil eines Komplexes der
elektronischen Kampfführung, wo also
gezielt mit dieser Drohne Nachrichten
versendet worden sind.
Als Beispiel, das hier anzusprechen ist,
ist der Einsatz von Drohnen Aufklärung in
Kombination mit Artilleriefeuer
im Juli 2014, wo eine ukrainische Brigade
im freien Gelände
durch den massiven Einsatz von Artillerie
und mehrfach Raketenwerfern zerschlagen
worden ist, im Raum Zelenopillya
mit sehr schweren Verlusten.
Das hat natürlich dazu geführt, dass die
ukrainische Seite begonnen hat, aus diesen
Erfahrungen zu lernen und in den
letzten Jahren bis zum
Konflikt umzusetzen.
Die ukrainische Seite hat es eine Reihe
von Drone Modellen der Klasse eins
und Klasse zwei sich beschafft.
Und gerade in den letzten Wochen erleben
wir auch viele Spenden oder Lieferungen
von Systemen, wie zum Beispiel dieses
System QUANTIX-RECON oder auch das System
VECTOR, das quasi für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte zur Verfügung
gestellt worden ist.
Zusätzlich zu den bereits beschafften
Klasse eins und Klasse zwei Drohnen hat
die ukrainische Seite auch dieses Modell
der Türkei, die BAYRAKTAR beschafft.
Die BAYRAKTAR TB2
zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass sie klein
und kompakt ist und Luft Boden Raketen
mitführen kann, die sie über den
entsprechend einsetzen kann.
Und Raketen der Typen.
MAM-L MAM-C
Oder gar MAM-T
Es ist wichtig zu verstehen, dass diese
Drohnen bereits 2020 das erste
Mal eingesetzt worden sind.
Hier sehen wir ein Bild, wo die
ukrainische Seite damals gezeigt hat, dass
sie mit diesen Drohnen in der Lage ist,
Radarstationen auf der Krim zu beobachten.
Ein Jahr später kam es dann zum ersten
Einsatz dieser Drohne,
wo eine Artillerie Stellung in den
Separatistengebieten durch eine
BAYRAKTAR beschossen worden sind.
Und am Beginn des Konflikts nach dem 24
Februar wurde diese Drohne eingesetzt, um
Ziele auf russischer Seite zu bekämpfen.
Interessant ist auch, dass die ukrainische
Seite sich Loitering Munition beschafft hat,
wie
zum Beispiel dieses Modell aus Polen.
WARMATE genannt, das die Idee dieser Drohne
ist es quasi, sich selbst in ein Ziel zu
stürzen und dort
Zerstörung zu verursachen.
Der Gefechtskopf lässt es auch zu, quasi
hohe Panzerungen zu durchschlagen.
Interessant wird die Anlieferung von
derartigen Modellen vonseiten
der NATO und der USA.
Die haben wir zwei Modelle, die
interessant sind das System SWITCHBLADE 300
oder
600, das sich in Zulieferung befindet, vor
allem für den Einsatz im Raum Donbass, wo
zurzeit ja der Kampf tobt bzw das zweite
System PHOENIX GHOST, wo man also auch
erwarten kann, dass diese Systeme
möglicherweise durchaus einen Effekt
auf dem Gefechtsfeld erzielen.
Sehen wir uns nun zusammengefasst zehn
Möglichkeiten an, wie man
Drohnen einsetzen kann.
Wie beginnen wir mit der ersten Möglichkeit
der klassische Einsatz zur Aufklärung.
Hier ein Beispiel einer russischen Drohne,
in diesem Fall eingesetzt von einem
tschetschenischen Kämpfer in Mariupol.
Diese Drohne vom Typ ZALA
unterstützt die russischen Streitkräfte
bei der Eroberung, indem sie ein
verbessertes Lagebild den
angreifenden Soldaten gibt.
Die zweite Möglichkeit ist es, aufgrund
der von der Drohne er flogenen Daten
gezielt Artillerie einzusetzen.
Hier könnte man zum Beispiel einsetzen endphasen
gesteuerte
Artillerie Munition, so wie das von
ukrainischer Seite passiert das, dass heisst
die
Drohne klärt ein Ziel auf
und die Artillerie Granate schlägt
gesteuert bis in dieses Ziel ein,
unter Umständen auch sogar mit
entsprechender Beleuchtung
von Seiten der Drohne.
An Drohnen können hier eine ganze Reihe
von Modellen eingesetzt werden, wie zum
Beispiel auch diese
handelsüblichen Mavic Pro Systeme.
Die nächste Möglichkeit wäre, wie schon
bereits erwähnt, die Drohne einzusetzen
zur Aufklärung
für Artillerie Systeme die eine Flächen
Wirkung erzielen, wie zum Beispiel in
diesem Fall die russische FORPOST Drohne
die Daten generiert auf deren Basis dann
eine Artillerie Batterie zum Beispiel
diese 2S19 Geschütze
ein Ziel bekämpfen können.
Die vierte Möglichkeit wäre, die Drohne
zu
beladen mit Abwurf Körpern, so wie sie zum
Beispiel sehr erfolgreich von ukrainischen
Spezialkräften in den ersten Wochen
des Konflikts eingesetzt worden sind.
Da wurden also Multi Copter verwendet.
Die wurden mit Abwurfmitteln versehen und
es war möglich, mit einer entsprechenden
Durchschlagsleistung
sogar mechanisierte Ziele zu zerstören.
Eine weitere Möglichkeit wäre, keine
Drohne zu verwenden, die mit Rotoren
ausgestattet ist, sondern eine Flächendrohne
mit entsprechender Zuladung, die es
möglich macht, auch gezielt Angriffe zu
fliegen, wie zum Beispiel dieses
ukrainische Modell UKRJET 22, von denen
wir aufgrund von dokumentierten Abstürzen
wissen, dass auch die
ukrainische Seite sie einsetzt.
Die Ukrainer haben auch selbst noch
zusätzlich Loitering Munition
entwickelt, zum Beispiel diese SD35
Womit wir bei der sechsten Aufgabe wären,
ist das Die Drohne stürzt sich selbst in
das Ziel und zerstört das Ziel quasi beim
Einschlag mit der entsprechenden Durchschlagseistung.
Die siebente Möglichkeit des Drohneneinsatz
ist es, Drohnen Systeme zu verwenden, um
mit der mitgeführten Luft Boden Raketen
über hohe Distanz Ziele zu bekämpfen.
Ein Beispiel ist die genannte BAYRAKTAR
Drohne, die Raketen mitführt, die aus
Entfernung zum Einsatz
gebracht werden können.
Der Vorteil ist, dass diese Drohne dadurch
nicht so leicht erkannt werden kann, weil
sie sehr klein und kompakt ist und einen
geringen Radarquerschnitt hat und der Einschlag
der Rakete überraschend erfolgt, wenn man
es nicht in der Lage ist, sie
entsprechend rechtzeitig zu detektieren.
Eine weitere Möglichkeit des
Drohneneinsatz ist es, eine Drohne zu
verwenden, um ein bestimmtes Ziel über
längere Zeit aufzuklären und dann
präzise zuschlagen zu können.
Als Beispiel hier diese russische ORION Drohne,
die sich dazu eignet, mit der Luft Boden
Raketen ein Hochwert-Ziel
ein High-Value-Target anzugreifen.
Indizien dafür gab es beim Einsatz vor
allem dieser Drohnen im Raum Kiew, wo wir
gesehen haben, dass der ukrainische
Präsident mehrmals vor sogenannten
Bluescreen aufgetreten ist, was ein Indiz
dafür ist, dass er nicht ins Freie
gegangen ist, weil eine hohe Gefahr
bestand, durch diese russischen Drohnen
gezielt ausgeschaltet zu werden.
Eine weitere Möglichkeit des Einsatzes ist
es, eine Drohne als
Plattform zu verwenden.
Hier wieder ein russisches Beispiel.
Die
Drohne Orlan zehn fungiert wie ein
fliegender Handymast als Teil
des Komplexes für elektronische
Kampfführung RB341, das heißt Handys
wählen sich erzwungenermaßen in die Drohne
ein und die Drohne kann dazu genutzt
werden, gezielt entsprechende
Nachrichten zu versenden.
Die nächste Möglichkeit des Drohnen
Einsatzes ist der Einsatz im Schwarm.
Hier ist es in der Definition so, dass
wenn der Schwarm miteinander kommuniziert,
wir tatsächlich von einem
intelligenten Schwarm sprechen.
Wenn jedoch mehrere Drohnen gleichzeitig
eingesetzt werden,
es dazu kommt, dass vor allem die Masse
im Ziel möglich macht zu erreichen.
In der Ukraine können wir möglicherweise
erwarten, dass diese SWITCHBLADE Drohnen oder
diese
PHOENIX GHOST Drohnen in hoher Zahl eingesetzt
werden
und damit quasi die gegnerischen
Abwehrsysteme auf russischer Seite
überfordert werden und diese Drohnen dann
eine entsprechende Effekt auf
dem Gefechtsfeld erzielen.
Der Einsatz von vielen Kamikaze Drohnen in
Schwärmen lässt natürlich die Frage
entstehen, ob der Panzer auch in Zukunft
noch seine Bedeutung auf
dem Gefechtsfeld hat.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass der Panzer die
einzige Möglichkeit darstellt,
Gelände in Besitz zu nehmen.
In einer Kombination aus Panzerung,
Feuerkraft und Beweglichkeit.
Möchte er dies auch in Zukunft erfüllen
können, muss aber geschützt
werden gegen diese Bedrohungen.
Das bedeutet, dass mechanisierte Verbände
entsprechend am Marsch zum Angriffsziel
geschützt werden müssen, wie
auch in der Vergangenheit.
Die Besonderheit besteht darin,
dass Kamikaze Drohnen sehr
kleine Radar Querschnitte haben.
Das heißt alle mitfahrenden Systeme der
Abwehr müssen in der Lage sein, die
Drohnen trotzdem zu erkennen und
entsprechend bewirken zu können.
Kommen viele Drohnen gleichzeitig zum
Einsatz, müssen die Abwehrsysteme so
gestaltet sein, dass diese vielen Drohnen
entsprechend bekämpft werden können.
Dann hat der Panzer auch in
Zukunft seine Bedeutung.
Als ein Beispiel habe ich hier das TOR M1
System der russischen Seite genommen,
von dem wir auch wissen, dass es sich
in der Ukraine Einsatz befindet.
Dieses System wurde aufgrund der
Erfahrungen der russischen Seite in Syrien
nachgerüstet, um gerade gegen kleine
Drohnen eingesetzt werden zu können.
Zum Schluss möchte ich
Ihnen dieses Bild zeigen.
Es zeigt eine russische ORLAN 10
Drohne, die von ukrainischer Seite
erbeutet worden ist und wo in
diesem Video kurz dargestellt wird.
Die Bauteile, die verwendet
worden sind von russischer Seite.
Im Video erkennt man, dass die Bauteile
sehr einfach gestaltet sind und im
Wesentlichen aus dem zivilen Bereich
stammen und nicht aus dem
militärischen Bereich.
Hier kann man in die eine oder in
die andere Richtung argumentieren.
Das eine ist natürlich, dass aufgrund des
Umstandes, dass es keine militärischen
Bauteile sind, die Qualität möglicherweise
nicht diese aufweist, die militärische
Bauteile, wie sie in Drohnen
verbaut sind, haben.
Die andere Seite ist aber, dass diese
Drohne zeigt, dass es sehr leicht ist, mit
handelsüblichen Produkten, also zum
Beispiel einem chinesischen Motor oder
auch Bauteilen, die man im Modellflug
bekommt, sehr rasch eine sehr
leistungsfähige militärische
Drohne zu erzeugen.
Wenn wir jetzt nur noch an die Möglichkeit
von Sanktionen denken,
so scheint es klar, dass derartige Drohnen
sehr schwer mit Sanktionen bekämpft werden
können, weil die Bauteile ja überall
auf dem Markt beschafft werden können.
Damit bin ich am Ende meiner Präsentation.
Sollten Sie ein weiteres Interesse haben
an der Drohnen Kriegsführung und was das
bedeutet, vor allem für das Völkerrecht,
so empfehle ich Ihnen mein Buch "Robotic Wars"
Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und
bis zum nächsten Mal.